PALI BHAT: Welcome, everyone.
Today we're going to talk about
Monetizing Digital Goods
With Google Wallet.
I'm Pali, a product manager
on the Google Wallet Team.
And I'm going to be joined today
by Dan and Joel, who are
software engineers on the team,
and Bryan, who's with
Kabam, a partner of
Google Wallet.
So I'm going to start off today
by talking a little bit
about Google Wallet for digital
goods and how it will
help developers monetize
their digital goods.
Then we're going to hand off to
Dan and Joel, here, to talk
about the integration process
for Google Wallet.
And we'll turn over to Bryan to
talk about their experience
with integrating with Google
Wallet and the experience
they've had with monetizing
their digital goods.
And want to wrap up with
some exciting news.
So if you stick around to the
end, there is some exciting
news coming up.
So first up, I want
to just level-set
everybody on Google Wallet.
How many of you have used
Google Wallet before?
Show of hands.
Wow, everybody.
Well, it was a little bit of a
trick question, because the
only way to purchase tickets
for I/O was by
using Google Wallet.
So you wouldn't be here
if you hadn't used
Google Wallet already.
In addition, we've got some
great booths set up if you
want to try out tap and pay.
So do come by our booth.
And we've got a Code Lab set up
if you want to try out and
actually do an integration.
So Google Wallet is just your
physical wallet that you put
it in the cloud, so it's
accessible from any device,
whether it's your desktop
computer or your mobile
device, so you have
it on the go.
Now Google Wallet for digital
goods is the same Google
Wallet, all the benefits we
talked about, but optimized
for digital content.
When we announced this
product last year, we
called it In-App Payments.
And since we launched, we've
learned that developers are
using this for a whole lot more
than just in-app payments.
So they're using it to monetize
all kinds of digital
content, whether it's virtual
swords within a game or
whether it's music videos,
online articles, et cetera.
So Google Wallet is really for
the gamut of all of the
digital content that developers
are looking to monetize.
And the beautiful thing about
Google Wallet is that it
already powers all of Google.
So if you look at the technology
behind payments for
Google Play, Offers, YouTube,
Google+ Games, Chrome Web
Store, all of this is powered
by Google Wallet.
And so developers get access
to the huge technology
investments that we put in to
make this the very best
product in terms of conversions,
in terms of
monetization for all the
Google properties.
And you guys have access
to it with Google
Wallet for digital goods.
After we've launched, a whole
lot of great developers are
already on board and
onto Google Wallet.
We're going to be joined by one
of them, Kabam, to talk
about their experience.
But we also have all of the
large brands, like Zynga,
Rovio, Gameloft, EA, et cetera,
already integrated
with Google Wallet.
So there's a ton of momentum,
and there's already hundreds
of developers on
Google Wallet.
And with today's announcements,
we're looking
to scale this much, much more.
Now when we started Google
Wallet, we looked at three key
principles.
The first principle was really
to have a streamlined
experience.
We wanted to make it as simple
to buy with Google Wallet as
it is to click a button
on the screen.
And if you look at signed-in
users today with Google
Wallet, that's all it takes.
And we're going to demonstrate
a little bit of that purchase
experience here.
But it's just one click,
and you're done.
The second key principle we
wanted to start off with was,
make it really simple to
integrate with this product.
And we're going to hit upon this
theme a lot more during
the rest of the session.
And a big, big point that we've
actually focused on, a
point of focus we've had
throughout this process of
launching Google Wallet for
digital goods, is to make the
integration very, very simple.
In many cases, developers have
told us that it takes just a
couple of hours to integrate.
And we'll demonstrate some
of that as well.
And the last one was, of course,
attractive pricing.
We wanted to make sure that we
increase developer bottom
lines as much as possible.
And we'll talk a little bit
more about this as well.
Now since we launched last year
at Google I/O, we've been
hard at work.
So we've done a bunch
of different things.
The first, of course, is that
in July and August, we
launched support for Chrome Web
Store and Google+ Games
developers.
So anyone on the Chrome Web
Store or Google+ Games can use
Google Wallet to monetize
their digital content.
And then, in the fall, we
streamlined the user
experience to this one-step
process that I just described.
In December of last year, we
expanded support from the
United States to 18
seller countries.
So if you're developers in any
of these seller countries, you
can start using Google Wallet
for digital goods right away.
And the other big win was
expanding this product to
140-plus buyer countries.
So you have buyers that you
can target across 140
countries on the planet.
We, of course, support nine
currencies as well.
Now in January, we launched
another big push with Google
Wallet in making the
signup easier.
And with the new signup flow
that we have, all we collect
from a new user is, apart from
your credit card details, just
your name and zip code.
And you can sign up, and
it's that simple.
And we've seen conversions
go up big-time after this
particular launch.
And then in March this year, we
launched Mobile Web Support.
The nice thing about Mobile Web
Support is now, if a user
actually comes to your site or
your app on a mobile device
and they're using a mobile
browser, we'll present to them
a streamlined mobile
web experience.
And the cool thing about this
is that you don't have to do
even one bit of work for this.
We just detect the device and
automatically present the
right flow, whether you're
coming through your PC, or
you're coming on your
mobile phone.
And the last couple of months
have been really, really busy
on our team--
Dan and Joel can attest
to that--
because we've been hard at work
on three cool things that
we want to talk about today.
And the first of them, of
course, is something that
we've got lots and lots of
feedback on throughout the
course of this launch
in this last year.
Developers love that we
allow single-item
purchases to be so simple.
But one of the consistent pieces
of feedback that we've
always got is, when are
you going to support
subscriptions?
So without further ado, as
of today, we support
subscriptions.
[APPLAUSE]
The nice thing about the
subscription functionality we
are doing is that it's as
simple to use as our
single-item purchase.
So the user has still just
this one-step process we
talked about.
A signed-in Wallet user just has
one step to subscribe to
your content, right?
They just click the Finish
button and they're done.
We're going to lunch with
monthly subscription support.
And we'll do free trials
right away.
And the coolest thing
about this is that
it's live in Sandbox.
So whether it's to go buy our
Google Wallet desk, which is
on the second floor, right on
this floor here, or the Code
Lab at 1:15 on Friday, you can
go in and try this out.
And feel free to knock on this
and go use this product,
because it's already live.
So look forward to all you
developers taking advantage of
this, including those who
are doing this live
stream on the web.
Now of course, once we launch
subscriptions, the first
question, of course, was how
would we do subscription
management?
And how would we give merchants
and developers the
way to do subscription
management, including
canceling subscriptions when a
user calls you, et cetera?
And so we're doing a
revamp of all our
merchant services as well.
And you guys will see this soon,
where we're going to
give you a much more streamlined
interface and
subscription management
functionality.
Pretty cool.
But while we were revamping
this, we figured, why don't we
just go ahead and improve
the analytics?
So when this new functionality
launches, we're going to give
you enhanced analytics.
So we've got all of this really
rich demographic data
that we're going to
bring to bear.
And we're going to give you
analytics, whether it's by
gender, by age, or country.
And we'll give you really cool
graphs to show you how your
sales have been trending as
you introduce new digital
content, new pricing
to your users.
You can take advantage of that
as soon as we launch this
functionality.
Now, with that, I want to hand
over to Dan and Joel to talk
about what's most important to
you guys, which is how easy
the integration is
going to be.
Dan.
DAN ZINK: All right.
Thanks, Pali.
Hi, I'm Dan.
JOEL LEITCH: And I'm Joel.
DAN ZINK: And we're both
engineers working on Google
Wallet for digital goods.
We'd like to talk a little bit
about integration right now.
So since we announced the
product a year ago, not much
has changed with integration.
What we do, if you want to
integrate with Google Wallets
for digital goods, what you do
is you create a JWT, or a J,
W, T, which stands for
a JSON Web Token.
This describes the thing
that you're selling.
I've got an example here
on the screen.
It's a data structure here that
holds the description of
a digital item being sold.
You can see in here, we've got
the issuer, which is the
person selling the item, the
audience, which is us, Google.
We've got an issued-at time
and an expiration date and
also a type.
The "type" field there
is important.
It's just "typ." It says
the type of purchase
that is being made.
That purchase is described
in the request
substructure in here.
And in there, you can see the
name, description, price, and
currency code of what's being
sold, along with an optional
field called "seller data."
Google does not interpret the
seller data.
We simply hold onto it and echo
it back to you later once
a purchase or a subscription
has been completed.
It's a good place to do your
own record-keeping.
So once you've created the JWT,
basically once you've
create that data structure and
run it through a JWT library
that will actually JSON encode
it, and base64 encode it, and
sign in with your secret key.
Then you need to pass it into
our JavaScript library.
We've tried to keep this
very simple as well.
What you would typically do
here is put your own "Buy"
button on your page,
bind the "Buy"
button to a click handler.
In this case, we've called it
"purchase." And in that
"purchase" function-- this is
just a JavaScript function--
you can pass the JWT into
our JavaScript Buy call.
Along with the JWT,
you can provide a
success and failure callback.
These, again, are just
JavaScript functions.
And they get called when
somebody exits the buy flow.
Now with subscriptions it's
really, really similar.
So if you've already integrated
for items, then
doing it for a subscription
should be pretty
straightforward.
I've highlighted the
changes in yellow.
The JWT structure is
slightly different.
Instead of being for an item in
the "type" field, it's for
a subscription instead.
And the contents of the request
substructure are
slightly different as well.
Instead of having the price and
currency code right there
in the request, we've got
another structure inside of
there that we call
a recurrence.
And in there we've got price,
currency code, and frequency.
So you can see in this example,
we're charging $4.99
a month, USD.
JOEL LEITCH: So wait
a second, Dan.
DAN ZINK: What, Joel?
JOEL LEITCH: We have
an audience full of
developers out here.
DAN ZINK: We do.
JOEL LEITCH: So let's just do
the live integration right
here on stage.
DAN ZINK: A live demo.
JOEL LEITCH: Yeah,
let's do it.
DAN ZINK: All right.
Do you have any site in mind
that you might want to
integrate with?
JOEL LEITCH: I do, actually.
You know my dogs, right?
DAN ZINK: Yeah, I
love your dogs.
JOEL LEITCH: So I have two
dogs, Pepper and Nutmeg.
They're pugs.
And I've written a
blog about them.
DAN ZINK: Oh, cool.
JOEL LEITCH: So why don't we
just integrate subscriptions
right into my blog.
DAN ZINK: Sounds like
a great idea.
So before we get started, I want
to go through the basic
steps we're going to do to
integrate with your blog.
We're going to first add a
buy button to your blog.
It's a button somebody can
click on to subscribe.
And then we're going to
go through building
a JWT on your server.
And then we're going to take
that JWT and pass it into our
JavaScript Buy function.
And then finally, the last step
is that we're going to
handle the postback.
And this is the server-to-server
call that
Google makes back to your server
once the payment has
been completed, whether it
be a subscription or a
single-item purchase.
JOEL LEITCH: OK, sounds good.
So why don't we start off by
taking a look at my blog?
DAN ZINK: Yeah, let's do that.
JOEL LEITCH: So there
you see it.
There's my pugs, Pepper
and Nutmeg.
DAN ZINK: Nice.
JOEL LEITCH: And some very,
very rich content on here.
DAN ZINK: Very nice.
JOEL LEITCH: But I'd like to
make some money off of this.
DAN ZINK: Sounds good.
JOEL LEITCH: So let's walk
through integrating
subscriptions then.
DAN ZINK: That sounds good.
So Joel, just to make
sure you've done
some prep work here.
Have you already created a
subscriptions database table
on your data store to
keep track of who's
subscribed and who isn't?
JOEL LEITCH: Yeah, I've
got that all set up.
DAN ZINK: OK, great.
So the first step that we want
to do here is adding a buy
button to your page.
So let's actually go into your
server code here and read the
state of a user, to see if
they're subscribed or not, and
then pass that into our web
template so we can show the
appropriate messaging.
And what we're going to want to
do is show some different
messaging for people that
are subscribed versus
unsubscribed.
JOEL LEITCH: OK.
So right now what I've got is,
you'll notice on line 36, I'm
reading from my data store.
I'm passing an email to figure
out whether or not this user
has subscribed.
Later down on line 40, I'm
just passing it into this
template values data structure,
which then
propagates into the
actual template.
So I'm going to open up the
template now, and I'm just
going to make sure this premium
content that you see
on line 10 gets hidden behind
that "has subscribed" flag.
DAN ZINK: That sounds great.
So again, we're showing people
who haven't subscribed a
"subscribe" button, and people
who have subscribed get the
premium content.
JOEL LEITCH: So now I've got the
premium content tucked in
behind the "if" statement
that you see on line 9.
So if they have subscribed,
they're going to see this
premium content.
And I'm a grateful guy,
so I'm going to thank
you for your support.
DAN ZINK: That's very nice.
JOEL LEITCH: And if they haven't
subscribed, you'll
notice the "else"
statement on 14.
And if they haven't subscribed,
I'm just going to
throw a Subscribe button
on the page.
And I'm actually hooking
it up to a purchase JS
function right now.
But we'll get in to implement
that later.
DAN ZINK: Let's take a look
at what this looks like.
We're going to reload
the page.
JOEL LEITCH: All right.
I see the Subscribe button.
DAN ZINK: All right.
Exactly as expected.
Nobody has subscribed yet,
including yourself.
So we're just showing
a Subscribe button.
So let's move on to
the next step.
Let's actually create the JWT.
So Joel, if you could open
up the server code.
I see you've done that.
So the next step is to create
that Python data structure
that describes the purchase.
Just like I showed on the slide
a few slides earlier,
we're going to create the
data structure, pass
it into a JWT library.
And I should've mentioned
earlier, these are available
across a number of programming
languages.
We're going to pass it in there,
which is going to turn
it into JSON and base64 encode
it, and sign it with your
secret key.
JOEL LEITCH: Yep.
So just going back up, you'll
notice what I've done here is
I've pasted in the
JWT payload.
That's the structure that you
saw a few slides ago.
In here, you'll notice
the issuer.
You'll notice I have
a seller ID.
That's just a constant
I stored in
another file for now.
I pulled out my seller ID from
the Merchant Center, as well
as I've got my seller secret
stored in the constant as well
in that same file.
Both of those pieces of
information are right off the
Merchant Center.
You'll notice the
"type" field.
That looks familiar to the
single-item JWT, other than
now we have "subscription"
in there.
And as Dan referenced earlier,
we have this recurrence
structure inside
of the request.
One other thing to note is, if
you look at line 47 here, I'm
just putting in the
user's email.
I'm going to be using this later
to determine whether or
not the user has subscribed.
And then I pass it into
JWT library, and I
call Encode on it.
Basically this will base64
encode the JWT payload and
then sign that structure.
And now what I'm going to do,
just so we can see some
progress, I'm going to put it
into the template so we can
see that it's actually
generating a JWT.
DAN ZINK: Now you normally
wouldn't show
this to your customers.
It does just look
like gibberish.
But it is base64 encoded JSON.
And in fact, if you ran it
through a base64 decoder, you
would see the original
data in there.
JOEL LEITCH: One other
thing to note.
The Subscribe button still
does not work.
DAN ZINK: JOEL: OK, so let's
move on to the next step here,
the third step.
Let's actually take that JWT
and pass it into the Buy
function from the Google Wallet
for digital goods
JavaScript library.
This will actually bring up
the buy flow and allow
somebody to subscribe.
JOEL LEITCH: OK.
So let me go back up
so we can see this.
Sorry about that.
What you're seeing on line 7
is us loading up the Google
Wallet library.
One thing to point out here on
line 10, we're pointing it at
the Sandbox configuration.
From line 7 to line 12
is all copy paste
right off our dev docs.
And then just below that, I've
implemented the Purchase call
that I said I would
implement later.
In here you'll notice
all I'm doing is
calling the Buy function.
And that Buy function
is supplied by the
library loaded above.
In there I'm just passing the
JWT that we generated on the
server side, and I'm
just setting up a
success handler here.
I left the failure handler
off just for this demo.
And all the success handler's
going to do, as you can see on
line 19, is it's just going
to reload the page.
And I'm going to leverage the
postbacks to actually figure
out whether or not the
user has subscribed.
DAN ZINK: So let's take a look
and see what this looks like
right now, now that we've got
all that code written.
OK.
So we actually have a
mostly working buy
flow at this point.
We're actually able to launch
the Payment dialogue.
You can see we're charging
$4.99 a month.
We're getting really
close right now.
The thing that we have not done
yet, though, is actually
recorded anywhere in our code
that somebody has subscribed.
So what we've got to do is
the last step, which is
implementing the postback
handler.
So when a purchase completes,
whether it's a single-item
purchase, the traditional API
that we've had for a year now,
or a subscription, Google's
going to send your server a
server-to-server postback to the
URL that you've defined in
your integration
settings page.
So Joel, if you could open up
your server code and go ahead
and write that.
Looks like you've
got that done.
JOEL LEITCH: Quick typer.
DAN ZINK: Very fast.
JOEL LEITCH: So just to explain
what's happening here,
Google will do a post
to your server
when a purchase completes.
It's going to post to a url that
you've specified in the
Merchant Center.
And what it does is it posts a
request to your server with a
JWT parameter.
So what I'm doing here is I'm
extracting that JWT parameter
out of the request, and then
I'm passing it through that
same JWT library.
But instead of encoding at this
time, I'm actually going
to decode it.
And what decoding will do, it
will base64 decode the JWT
payload, and it'll also verify
that the signature is correct.
So if we get past this point,
we have a decoded JWT.
And the next thing I recommend
doing is making sure that this
JWT was actually
meant for you.
To do this, all you have to do
is check that the issuer is
from Google and that the
audience is your seller ID.
If all is good at this point,
what I'm doing here is I'm
just pulling out the order ID
more for record keeping.
And I'm extracting that
email that I had put
in the seller data.
And I'm going to then store this
in my data store so I can
tell when a user comes
back whether
or not they're described.
And on line 78-- this is an
important point here-- on line
78, what we're going to do is
we're going to echo the order
ID back in the response so
Google knows that we've
completed processing
this request.
DAN: So that's all there
is to it, really.
We tried to keep the
integration very
straightforward.
So we should have something
that's working right now.
But there's one problem that
we haven't addressed yet.
And the problem that we haven't
addressed is that
we've been doing all of this on
Joel's laptop, and that's
on the Google I/O network.
And the server-to-server call
won't work from here.
To fix this, we'll have to
push the App Engine.
JOEL: Yep.
But in the interest of time, I
actually pushed this exact
code just a couple hours ago.
So I'm just going to go hit
my App Engine instance.
You'll notice the content looks
exactly the same as my
local host.
I'm going to click on the
Subscribe button.
This is going to pop
up the Google
Wallet payment dialogue.
One thing you'll notice, it's
still Pay to Pug Lover.
Just below that, you'll see
my list of credit cards.
You'll notice I have
one expired.
And I'm just going to complete
this purchase with my AmEx.
And there we go.
Purchase went through.
Or subscription went
through, actually.
DAN ZINK: OK, so now
your JavaScript
success handler is called.
The page is reloaded.
JOEL LEITCH: And there
it is. "Thank you for
your support!" [APPLAUSE]
DAN: So to recap here, we've
gone through four steps to do
this integration.
We added a Buy button
to Joel's page.
We built a JWT on the server.
We passed the JWT into the
JavaScript function that the
library provides.
And then we wrote a
postback handler.
So we've been trying to keep
this really straightforward,
try to make it as simple
as possible.
But don't just take
our word for it.
We've got Bryan from Kabam
here, who's done an
integration with us.
And he'd like to
tell you more.
Welcome, Bryan.
BRYAN SCHWAB: Thanks.
Hey, everyone.
I'm Bryan Schwab, and I lead
the Payments Team at Kabam.
And really happy to
be here today.
This is my first Google I/O. And
what I'd like to talk to
you about today is a little bit
about what we do and how
we've integrated Google
Wallet into our games.
[INAUDIBLE]
developers about integration,
as well as some tips for
monetization.
Kabam is one of the leaders
in social games.
We make games specifically
for hard-core gamers.
Some of our top games are
Dragons of Atlantis, Kingdoms
of Camelot, The Godfather:
Five Families, Thirst of
Night, Edgeworld, and others.
The Godfather was our first game
that we partnered with a
major movie studio.
This game was really important
for us because it was the
first game that we launched
exclusively on Google+.
This game was on no other social
platform at the time.
We also included it in the
Google Chrome store as well.
And we were really happy
with this integration.
And Google was really great
about helping us with any
problems that we had, ironing
out, and making sure that we
got this launched on time.
So it was a really positive
experience.
Now I want to get into a few
tips to help you with your
integration.
First off, you should definitely
read through all
the documentation, play with
the sample code, before you
even start coding.
Really understand that
whole flow and how it
works in your mind.
Break down the front end and
back end, and how it works.
For our team, this is really
helpful, because once you
understand the whole situation
on how the platform works, you
can really break down the tasks
in the sprint and assign
it to different developers and
bring it together later.
Next, the JWT is
very important.
So make sure that you use the
libraries that are provided.
There's libraries provided
for multiple
different programming languages.
Bring those into your
project and use it.
There's no need to reinvent
the wheel.
Especially because JWT errors
can cause problems in the
transaction, it won't work.
So you don't want that at all.
Another thing you want to do
is create a unit test, such
that when you generate your JWT
code, you check it with
what's provided in
the sample code.
You want to make sure those
match up so you know and
you're pretty sure that
everything works correctly.
For us, we had a problem when
we were first working with
this code that the JWT wasn't
generating correctly.
So we drilled down to the
specific class where it was
happening, and we fixed
the problem.
But then we followed it up by
writing a unit test and making
sure that that unit test always
checked that code to
make sure it was working.
And then we never had that
problem anymore.
Next, the Sandbox.
The Sandbox is very helpful.
Really, this is the first time
where your front end and back
end are going to come together,
and you're really
going to be testing
them as one unit.
This is also the first time,
as you've seen earlier, how
you're going to get real data
into your postback handler.
So this is important to test
and make sure that the
postback handler is handling the
transaction correctly, and
you're seeing the output of
everything in the database,
and everything looks great.
Another good thing about this
is that, in the Sandbox, you
have test credit cards.
I was going to give out Pali's
credit card number today, but
I'm sure he wouldn't
like that.
Send it out to a wider audience
in your team, and
have everybody bang on it.
And make sure if you find out
any issues you can address it
there in the Sandbox
before you go live.
For us, this was great.
When we were on the road to
finishing up Godfather, we
were testing in the Sandbox.
We had a tight iteration loop.
And then it was really great to
just flip the switch and go
from Sandbox to production.
It was very easy.
So take advantage of
that resource.
One of our top games
is Edgeworld.
And we make games for
hardcore gamers.
Our games involve strategy,
action, combat, and teamwork.
Edgeworld is a game where it
immerses players in an epic
battle to take over this
abandoned alien world.
And so what I'd like to do is
jump into the game right now
and show you how our Google
Wallet integration looks.
So here's my online base.
And I've built up
my troops, and I
think I'm pretty powerful.
So I'm going to go and
attack somebody.
Find a base that I've been
trying to attack for a while
now and send out some
troops and see if I
can win this time.
As we load the base--
let me pull up the Warp Gate,
select some units.
I'll send this particular unit
in, along with a few of these.
Send them into battle.
Now, I can kind of tell off
hand that that probably
doesn't look very good.
Doesn't look like I'm
strong enough.
But in my head I thought
I was powerful enough.
But I guess that's
not gonna happen.
Yeah.
The black there.
That's me.
So I'm dead.
So I'm going to leave
that base and
pretend that never happened.
I really need to get some
more powerful units.
And our in-game currency
here is platinum.
So I'm going to go in and get a
little bit more platinum so
that I can train my troops.
And I'm just going to
select one of the
payment options here.
And the cool thing about this
is now, with the streamlined
experience, I didn't have to
log in or do anything.
So I'm really happy
about that change.
And earlier today, I actually
signed up for
this amazing pug blog.
So I already had my credit
card in here.
So let me select that credit
card, hit Finish.
Hopefully it'll go through.
Hit OK, and then back
to the game.
So as you can see, those
new changes really
made it pretty simple.
My time spent in paying was
pretty small, which is great.
Another thing I want to talk
about is best practices for
monetization.
What you should do in your game
is create a price matrix
of all of your in-game currency
versus some of the
major currencies out there,
not just USD, but British
pounds, euros.
Then you want to geolocate
your users.
You want to find out where
they're coming
from into your game.
There's plenty of libraries out
there that you can import
into your project.
There's free databases
to help with this.
Once you have that, what you
want to do is hit them with a
combination of finding out where
they're coming from, and
then present them with the
language that's native to
them, as well as the currency.
Now this is important for your
conversion, because users are
used to thinking in their own
currency, calculating worth,
as well as reading
the language.
As you can see here, we have an
example of a user coming in
from Europe.
And the code we've detected,
they've come from Germany.
So we've served up the language
as German as well as
provided them the options
to purchase in euros.
Next, you want to think about
scaling your bonus items, if
you have bonus items.
We provide bonus items as part
of the package of buying
in-game currency.
And so what's key here is to
not just do a one-to-one of
price point to in-game currency
to bonus items.
You want to scale those bonus
items up to make those higher
price points attractive.
And lastly is gifting.
Gifting was really successful
for us.
As you can see in this type of
game, it's really hard to
become powerful.
And as you invite your friends,
they usually start in
a level where they're
not powerful at all.
So in order for everybody to
have fun, what happens is
their friends will gift them
items so that they can get up
to a higher level of power.
And everybody has a great
time at that point.
So it's really helpful.
Lastly, I'm going to leave you
with a few more tips when
you're working with
Google Wallet.
First is make your postbacks
idempotent.
This is important because you
want to be able to send the
transactions over and over
again, have the code check for
duplicates.
Where this helped us out was we
had a problem one time when
there was a timeout
in the database.
So we were able to just resend
that transaction again.
The database was up, and
it went through.
Another place where this helps
you out is if you have a huge
list of test transactions.
And what you can do with that
is you can just send the
matcher postback and
really slam it.
And make sure that the load and
performance is there and
looks good before you go live.
Next is you want to track
everything about payments.
I cannot stress this enough.
Any time that someone is in
your payments flow, in the
funnel, you want to track
everything that they do to
find out where they drop off.
This is also important when
you're doing A/B testing.
When you have a hypothesis, you
want to make sure that you
can determine which one
is the successful one.
So record everything.
There's a lot of variables going
on here, IP addresses,
what they've chosen as their
price point, what the currency
that was served, everything that
comes in with a postback.
Just record everything.
And lastly, think about other
countries outside of the US.
The easy ones to pick off
right away are Canada,
Australia, and the UK.
But also think about FIGS,
which is France, Italy,
Germany, and Spain.
And the cool thing about Google
Wallet is you can just
have your USD bank account.
Google Wallet will take care of
all the translation of all
those currencies into yours.
So thank you, everybody.
I hope these tips
will help you.
I really enjoyed being
here today.
And hopefully this will help
you with your integration.
As you can see from the final
result, the new streamlined
purchase flow is very nice.
And hopefully it'll also help
you with your monetization.
And for some really exciting
news about Google Wallet,
here's Pali.
PALI BHAT: Thanks, Bryan.
[APPLAUSE]
PALI BHAT: You know, I guess
we put this slide together
before we saw Sergei's
skydiver stunt.
So there's a new bar for
exciting at this year's Google
I/O. But I think this will
still be really, really
interesting to you guys.
So last year when we announced
the pricing for in-app
payments, it was huge.
It was 5% flat for all
your transactions.
And that was a great rate
for developers.
We've been getting amazing
feedback about this rate from
developers who've integrated
with us and developers who're
looking to integrate with us.
One of the things that we've
always been trying to do is
figure out how we can make
it better for developers.
And as some of our developers
have gotten traction, like
Kabam and others, they started
to create these price matrices
where they give different
levels of buy-in to the
players of their game,
in Kabam's case.
And they have goods that they're
selling everywhere
from $1 to $5, all the way
up to transactions that
are $300 at a time.
And of course, the feedback we
get is that 5% is awesome when
you do a $1 transaction, because
all Google Wallet
takes from you is $0.05.
But it could be better for
larger transactions.
So if it's $100 transaction or a
$300 transaction, how do you
make it better for developers?
And the usual approach that all
of the solutions in the
market take is that
they create a
micro transaction rate.
This is like the 5% rate we
have, which is really awesome.
And then they create another
rate, which is for larger
transactions, or regular
transactions.
And that rate usually is tiered
along different volume
structures.
So if you are higher volume,
you get a lower rate.
It's all sorts of confusing
tier structures.
In fact, you probably need a
degree to figure out how this
pricing works.
And they usually have
long FAQ documents.
That's usually the first sign
that this pricing is super
complicated.
So what we did was try to
simplify it all, and try to
figure out how we can make
it better for both micro
transactions and large
transactions, and just have
one price structure that
works for everybody.
So today, we want to announce
a new rate.
And that's 5%, or
1.9% plus $0.30.
I'll repeat that.
It's 5%, or 1.9% plus $0.30.
Of course, if you're a developer
in a different
country, this fixed
fee will change.
What's different about
this rate?
What's different is Google will
automatically apply the
lowest fees for every
transaction.
We're not going to force you
to pick whether you're a
micro-transaction developer or a
large-transaction developer.
We'll just figure it out, and
we'll apply the lowest
transaction.
The second thing is we're not
going to have any volume
restrictions.
Right from your first
transaction, we'll give you
the lowest fee.
Bryan, how does that
sound to you?
[APPLAUSE]
BRYAN SCHWAB: I'll tell you
that my CFO is going to be
happy about that.
PALI BHAT: Yeah, indeed.
And the commitment that Google
Wallet has to all you
developers is that we're
committed to increasing your
bottom line.
For Google, we want to make sure
that you have the best
rate, and you don't have to
think about whether it's small
transactions or larger
transactions.
The best thing is that as of--
Joel and Dan, what
was it, 3:00 PM?
DAN ZINK: Yeah, something
like that.
PALI BHAT: Something
This has just gone live to all
existing and app payments
developers.
OK?
So if you are Google Wallet for
digital goods, and you're
using it today, you've done this
integration, everyone's
got this price automatically.
And if you integrate tomorrow,
or you try it out in the Code
Lab, 1:15 on Friday, we'll
just give it to you
automatically.
So starting from this point
on, this price is live.
So I want to wrap up and cover
what we talked about today.
The first thing is Google
Wallet is optimized for
digital content.
Doesn't matter what kind
of digital content.
You don't have to have an app.
It doesn't have to be
in-game currency.
It could be in-game currency
and in-app payments.
It could be digital
content, like
music, that you're selling.
Or it could be Joel's
pug blog.
Whatever it is, you can monetize
using Google Wallet.
The second thing is that our
integration is really simple.
It's as simple as a few hours.
Of course, if you're Dan
and Joel, it only
takes you 10 minutes.
Right?
The third is we announced
earlier that we'll support
both single-item purchases and
subscription purchases.
This is already live
in Sandbox.
You can go try it
out right now.
The fifth thing I want to talk
about is how can you increase
your bottom line.
That new pricing that we showed
you is a huge step
towards increasing
your bottom line.
Other thing, of course, is that
convergence matters more
than everything else.
And with our streamlined flow
and streamlined signup, you
should have amazing conversion
with Google Wallet.
So in terms of next steps, I
just want to cover a quick few
next steps.
First, we have a Code Lab
on Friday at 1:15.
Do make sure you stop by.
And we can even show you how
to integrate with new
subscriptions right away.
We've given a set of links,
developer documentation,
creating an account,
and you can also
follow us on our blog.
Of course, if you want to go
back over the slide deck,
we've given a link
to that, too.
Before I wrap up and invite over
Dan, Joel, and Bryan for
questions, I want to just send
out a big thank-you to all you
developers from Google Wallet.
The reason for us building these
products is so you guys
can use it.
So thank you for your support.
And we hope with today's
announcement, you can monetize
your digital content much, much
better and increase your
bottom line while doing it.
Guys, if you want
to come over.
And of course, in true Google
I/O form, this entire
presentation was built in
HTML and impress.js.
So huge thank-you to the
guys who built this and
open-sourced it.
And of course, we use some of
the cool pictures that are out
there on Flickr with the
Creative Commons license.
So with that, if you have any
questions, we're all happy to
answer them.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi, question
over here.
If you're going to look into
international markets, the tax
ramifications on these
charges, how are they
determined?
How do you know?
PALI BHAT: How do
we determine--
AUDIENCE: For instance,
say you do a
transaction in France.
Obviously, there's some amount
of money, from a tax
perspective, that has to be
remitted back to France, or to
you, or wherever.
How do you find your
notification, or how do you
actually determine
that amount?
PALI BHAT: OK.
So there are two
kinds of taxes.
So one is the tax that the user
pays, so the buyer pays,
and the tax the developer then
has to pay the same amount.
So on the buyer side, it's
really, really simple.
We use tax tables that are
provided by both the developer
on our Merchant Center and
determine where the location
of the buyer is.
So when they sign up for Google
Wallet, they have to
provide us their instrument
and their billing address.
So we use that to determine
what the taxes are.
And of course, all developers
can go into our Merchant
Center, look at every order,
determine what the tax
ramifications of those are,
and then appropriately
complete their taxes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PALI BHAT: Thank you.
Please.
AUDIENCE: What do you recommend
for a three-party
transaction?
Like I use the Paypal API, and
it allows me to take a cut,
pay the event director most
of it, and the credit card
payment happens once.
Do you have any help for that?
PALI BHAT: Yeah, so
great question.
So what you're looking for is
how do I partition and do a
rev share to a third party?
With our current integration,
we've tried to keep it really,
really simple.
And part of that simplicity is
that, today, we don't allow
you to rev share to
a third party.
However, this is something
that we are
actively looking at.
So stay tuned in to our blog,
and you might see some
exciting announcements
come up.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you mentioned in the demo,
showed off in the demo,
rather, the seller information
that you put in.
You used the email
in your example.
What extra metadata is
available for those
transactions?
Obviously, if I missed that
callback that's made by Google
Wallet for whatever reason, I'm
going to have to have some
kind of backup that runs
on a scheduled basis.
Can I get those transactions
back through the API in order
to make sure that my records
are correct?
JOEL LEITCH: So if you were
to miss a postback--
there was that one important
step that I mentioned that--
writing out the order ID
into the response.
If that actually fails, then we
would actually terminate,
or cancel, the order.
And you can reconcile that
in the Merchant Center.
AUDIENCE: Any kind of general
transaction data?
If I want to run my own
analytics, for example, or I
lose my data for whatever
reason, and I want to recreate
my database?
JOEL LEITCH: So all the
transaction information is in
Merchant Center.
You can pull some reports off
Merchant Center and then do
the reconciliation in
an offline process.
PALI BHAT: So you can definitely
do that on the
Merchant Center site.
And if you want to dive in
further, you can just stop by
one of our booths or in the Code
Lab on Friday, 1:15, and
we'll be happy to work through
some of the ideas with you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PALI BHAT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Quick question about
the user interface.
Does it automatically detect
the mobile browsers and
launches the Play application,
or--
JOEL LEITCH: What we're showing
you right now is a
web-based UI.
It will detect if you're on a
desktop web interface or a
mobile web interface and show
you the appropriate flow.
It does not kick over
to Google Play.
PALI BHAT: Any other
questions?
OK.
If nothing else, thank
you for coming.
Really enjoyed having
you guys here.